next up American refugee by Allison Buck
melter and Nicolas buck melter with
missiles raining down on American cities
and the nation under martial law a rural
family has no choice but to seek shelter
in a neighbor's bomb shelter where the
danger inside is potentially greater
than the danger outside Helen and her
family are welcome and winters bunker
for one reason only because winters wife
Amber is pregnant and Helen is an OB guy
who can help her the impending birth
means the end of Helens claim to safety
in winter space unless she can find
other ways to remain indispensable in
this scene the two families have just
repelled a breach by armed intruders
winter is in a rare festive mood and
Helen finds her opening to take a
dangerous gamble exterior winters
property don't Don thin wisps of cloud
lie low over the clearing in the Morning
Sun the bodies of five intruders are
strewn about the field their vehicles
pierced with bullet holes interior
bunker living room dining room day amber
Greg and Helen sit around the table too
exhausted to make conversation
Greg tries regions for Helens hand
suddenly winter barges in wild-eyed and
manic after last night we deserve a
break a celebration I was leaving this
for the little ones arrival but let's
crack it open now when you say Greg it's
a little early let's do it yeah interior
bunker living room dining room later
that night Zoe and Matthew too tired for
the pullout sleep on the sofa across the
room Helen and winter remain at the
table a candle burns as they finish off
the bourbon everything before now seems
so trivial you know we spend our free
time remodeling the kitchen driving
Quaeda speech we should have been
getting ready like you well we were
delivering babies that's that's
important Helen shrugs finishing her
glass her hand trembles noticeably Jory
Helen nods and shakes her hand trying to
get it to relax
hey it takes a lot to kill a man I'm no
stranger to blood but up there I felt
like something else well there's nothing
more savage than a lioness with her cubs
in danger I felt like I was taken over
like I could see it happening before I
actually and it felt felt good hmm you
did good out there
winter holds a bottle up Helen extends a
clasp I delivered a baby once
Afghanistan we were we were in this
Canyon
taking fire from a bunch of 12-year olds
I see a little mud brick house I take
cover
inside there's a little girl all alone
scared to death with a baby's head
halfway out of her I go to help
she's screaming kicking at my face we
struggle she's pushing and out pops the
baby this little boy right into my hands
yeah the girl died an hour later whom I
knew right then I needed to get home
protect my own boy I figured it was only
a matter of time before things fell
apart over you what was it like coming
home after that it's hard found out my
wife slept with someone
guy even took Matthew trick-or-treating
so you two divorced no no no no I loved
him
she's beautiful had long barber and hair
but she passed soon after we were
fighting she had too much to drink we
both did
she took off on a jeep and just like
that just everything's gone Helen shakes
her head they look at each other quietly
for a moment and self-conscious Helen
hides her hair behind your ears her gray
roots are beginning to show winter
reaches across a table and untucked her
hair she snatches his hand and then
slowly softens her grip a knock on the
door
the couple turns to find amber standing
in the doorway clutching her belly
something's happening
Helen Rises immediately not giving
winter another glance exterior winters
property dawn amber
moaning braces herself against the tree
while Hill interrupts her back is it
over the contraction I'm sorry the
baby's coming early you don't have to be
sorry it's not that even that's it's not
that early even just two weeks still
considered full-term no I'm I'm sorry
for you for your family I liked having
you guys around
Helen takes us in then she comes a piece
of Amber's long auburn hair out of her
eyes
[Applause]